what's happening y'all man happy
birthday was that vodka
first of all i was never a vodka guy
never actually you know i did enjoy uh
sorak so oh yeah diddy's uh
oh yeah that's right off that that [ __ ]
was good
i only [ __ ] with whiskey and then uh
jelly roll gave us
uh what was that tequila jordan
he gave us jordan's tequila at in zany's
and yeah
no not yeah me that's right
hoes but then uh at at theo's house
you tried it too chin didn't you try cat
yeah he gave it throughout and i think
it was either george clooney or the
rocks tequila the rock
rocks that [ __ ] was fantastic i didn't
know the rock hats cute oh yeah big time
damn everybody in the alcohol industry
yeah i think i'm not
i'm thinking about it uh liquor is
insane really you think about dude you
don't even drink
thinking about well i think i i don't
think uh 50 cent drinks no we don't
but he has uh his uh
no cognac alcohol just put
it's lemur there that's the shenanigans
champagne no it's he says he he yeah he
has tags that he has
i know cognac there it is
the rocks are killing then george
clooney sold his tequila too that's my
dude
well the markup on liquor the markup on
shoes is insane mark up on coffee you
know a cup of coffee costs about eight
cents for starbucks
everything included cup the whole
bang everything richard coffee eight
cents
you [ __ ] with starbucks oh yeah oh you
[ __ ] with it well i'm a coffee
connoisseur
but the reason why i [ __ ] with
starbucks especially the christmas a
little bit more convenient
they they don't miss like if i go to
starbucks up the street here in santa
monica
and i go to starbucks in [ __ ]
thailand or ireland it's the
exact same the consistencies now it's
not the best coffee in the world but
it's pretty [ __ ]
you know if you just want a nice cup of
joe that you can depend on you don't
like coffee bean
no is coffee being worldwide i think so
coffee beans started here
oh and coffee means yeah california
based oh [ __ ] i didn't know that right
that's got to be a wild industry to get
into though
yeah that's a huge markup on coffee yeah
huge
your guy who we uh matt best uh yeah
yeah i love black rifle coffee that's
why i usually drink every morning
oh really yeah seems very strong yeah
that's what i love
punching in the dish you don't like
coffee either i'll do a
iced uh vanilla latte with oat milk
yeah that doesn't count you don't drink
coffee either drink coffee
and you don't eat i gotta do one shot
really i don't have a coffee every
single day i just drink it before i get
just one cup yeah usually tom brady
doesn't drink coffee
but he doesn't no he never had a sip no
i wonder why well i don't know some
people are just like wired already just
to start their morning i mean that's how
i am too so i can have it i'll do it
like once a week
because you get wired off coffee yeah oh
i get two why do you drink energy drinks
no oh why you made that face oh because
the thing is like if i have a red bull
like let's say i had a red bull at our
show this weekend uh palm beach thursday
friday saturday let's say
let's say i had a red bull yeah before i
went on stage i wouldn't sleep that
night
oh really it's something it's something
energy drinks that [ __ ] with like my
the the the [ __ ] chemistry with my
body my heart will be fluttering all
night yeah
which is weird because i could i could
drink six shots of expression
straight so red bull like john mccoy joe
coy had he had a coffee
it was yeah he had six shots americano
yeah
he's like me yeah i'm like god damn see
i'll do that and i'll be i
can go straight to bed but i can't i had
to make it i can't have a half a red
bull and go to bed so what why because
it does it has like all that taurine or
whatever the [ __ ] else is in it
all the b vitamins like it's man what's
the craziest energy drink
i don't even think that's the craziest
one no red line
red light red lines like pre-workout
[ __ ] right
but then remember there was four locos
alcoholics
i think it was like alcoholic like
energy drink no
but there but there was it was like four
lokos that was straight energy drink and
it was like dangerous because i think
you had ephedrine in it oh
they took them off the market because i
know they changed the recipes
ago i know i honestly think it was no it
was it was always been alcohol right
it's like looks like it is always
alcohol four loca
then was there's another one there's
another one there not for our energy
right
no that's oh do you do that though no
that's for [ __ ] is that oh that's not
get the [ __ ] they had cool commercials
that's like uh whatever
no people dig it but i mean come on um
not but strongest not most popular used
to be
i mean that's going to be monster red
bull those are just yeah
sure we'll give you liquid death no
that's water
the most powerful damn 10 hour energy
shot that's a oh [ __ ] red damn 10 hour
energy shot has more
caffeine than red line [ __ ]
what's bang i see them promoting that on
instagram bangs like
a healthy all-natural oh got it bang is
like the ig
equivalent of skinny fit teeth for like
instagram workout people
oh okay like if you're really fit and
you uh
your whole thing is fitness and health
you usually get a bang energy drink
sponsored
yeah uh okay get a bang damn 10
hour energy that's that's 10 hours
bro so so i
correct me if i'm wrong five hour energy
drink is the same people at 10 hour
energy yeah i think so they doubled up
yeah they probably heard seven minutes
talk about it
seven minutes from uh something about
mary
what ben stiller oh my god beat me up
later guys remember when he massaging
she was like oh my god jail and she
rubbed it and she had the little stick
he's all he
he uh he picks up that hitchhiker who's
a serial killer oh yeah
i've never seen it well he gives he
pitches him he pitches him he goes
uh how about seven minute abs
and he's oh that's cool he goes well
someone comes out six minutes
he's off those six minute abs because
you wouldn't break a sweat in six
minutes
yeah you step in my office fight cause
you're [ __ ] fired
yeah yeah springs and beans frankin
beans
um yeah yeah energy i i mean i [ __ ] with
monster for a while
that stuff just isn't good for you it
doesn't like none of this there's just
too much [ __ ] in there
yeah i would see people like have it
like for breakfast and [ __ ] i'm like bro
you gross
it's very fascinating like that like he
was like first thing in the morning i
know i'm like god damn like
yeah but i mean some people could just
take it like it's nothing i mean real
like coffee connoisseurs who like like
one like first thing in the morning
that's what i do they don't they take it
black
like real coffee drinkers drink it black
they don't have cream sugar
none of that stuff i don't add any sugar
any sweetener yeah i might do a splash
of almond milk but usually it's just
black
yeah see i like i like a good taste like
of the
uh vanilla latte or like a mocha like
latte i like the taste of it yeah
just once a week once a week once a week
i used to drink it a lot and then i was
getting like all [ __ ] up and there's a
lot of calories in it
yeah well i i said once again i know i'm
just saying
you don't really drink coffee right chin
i drink one every morning
but now i'll drink more because my
girlfriend bought me a keurig
for christmas oh i don't know i don't
[ __ ] that's great that's you don't like
this
it's a tesla of [ __ ] coffee that's a
great
no like real car guys don't [ __ ] with
tesla's well really i bought stock
awesome rogan well because he had
[ __ ] uh you know almost a show and
then
i think he felt pressured to buy one
you don't like the teslas i love them i
thought you said like they're don't you
test the truck
the truck looks cool they would test the
truck now would i take the
giant the trucks don't see it now i take
the tesla truck over like the new raptor
[ __ ] no hell no you had that raptor too
yes that's a tesla truck yeah it
actually looks like that too no it's
just drawing yeah it does
wow elon musk pulled up to uh was that
morton's off uh
pch in it mm-hmm damn that steak is that
the steakhouse yeah
it's open too by the way they refuse to
shut down down there
they can do that um
they refuse to shut down astros is good
yeah
i love their crab cakes i can't eat crap
do you know shellfish yeah bro when's
the last time you had it though
[ __ ] the last well you know anytime i go
to any place that
has like that type of food or anything
like that i'll always get a reaction
what do you mean it means like i don't
know like when we went to the steakhouse
in uh
boise they they have crabs but they had
a pretty large menu
so like they probably have their are you
saying if they like specialize in fish
yeah no one like i went i remember
uh because i was like man [ __ ] it i'm
gonna try it again i went had uh
sushi back home uh by myself and i was
like hey
i'm allergic to shellfish and avocado i
was like do you have anything that does
not have that no
yeah we got you still had a reaction
maybe because what
they made it on the same ship yeah
that's what i was thinking like they
probably just like
cross contamination yeah yeah that's
what it's so it's like i
i don't even like to just you know at
all because like
uh like if i like pokey too so sometimes
like
i'll go to a pokey spot and you can't
even have people yeah
you know still i'll still because like
my son was allergic to eggs as a baby
but you just keep giving to them and
then their body just gets over it
fights it off should i just do that i
don't know you're pretty old now
yeah you know what you don't think it'll
work that way i don't know it works for
kids
was your son uh allergic to eggs or was
he like
had an intolerance to it because i think
being allergic to something and being
intolerant to it is
two different things uh
he had allergic reactions like his neck
would get red he'd get splotches on his
face just keep giving it to him he'd
power through it
he was like now he has eggs every
morning that was a good super saiyan
all right it was you have eggs every
morning damn
you're not allergic to anything huh um
no the food wise no i have allergies
yeah yeah yeah but no [ __ ] allergies
yeah remember i was taking that afrin
oof
i just got over it by the way i just
kicked that habit time is just good bro
i [ __ ] myself
up with that he thought it was just
saline solution yeah
[Music]
i didn't know you that's supposed to
like you're only supposed to take it
like what two days
and most likely you start to you start
you keep spraying that for three days
your nose starts to clog up yeah sorry
then you can't breathe without it
yeah and i was like why is my nose so
clogged and then
i was like let me see that [ __ ] oh hell
yeah i got it when i was in arizona
because whenever i go to arizona yeah
born and raised there but allergies but
allergies
denver what me yeah oh yeah if you have
allergies wait did you get to dance
i took this guy to my neighborhood and
he laughed where i grew up why
because i mean well it the struggle but
i mean
oh was it was it was it feels busted but
i mean i've been around i couldn't get
an [ __ ]
i was like hey man that's where i grew
up he's off man
no cause we was doing good no we're
doing good now so i'm figuring like why
are you showing me this like i don't
know where
it came from i'm just showing you where
i grew up mesa arizona go to louisiana
the neighborhood didn't have street
lights you know how tough that was yeah
that's tough
no streets no street lights no street
lights that's some country [ __ ] though
sometimes that doesn't mean poor it just
means country
country because there's some places you
go in like the the country where
they got one stop light yeah no no
street signs yeah it's just yeah
we took off it was a stop sign in my
yard right and then so we had a big
front yard
and it was a stop line stop sign right
there and we kicked it over
and we brought it all the way back it's
illegal yeah
oh we we had to make a basketball goal
so what we did was let's go
yeah we had a little boxes that's why
hooping me yeah basketball yeah i don't
call it a goal ever again
what was a customized basketball yeah i
know but not you guys played basketball
all of his life
scored goals man i scored 50 goals one
time
all right well you're not a basketball
head well i had a set shot and speaking
of basketball
happy birthday to the goat appreciate
you is it lebron's b day yeah how old
uh he's 36. father time is he 36. why
are you tapping your wrists like that
okay so let's just go back and just like
go 36 look at that so that's him right
there
how long do you think he could he could
play uh let's give him two years
where he's still going to be like
you know why we don't know and i know
you're not gonna like this you know why
we don't know
pds what's that human growth hormone oh
god
steroids let's not listen you're crazy
if you don't think he's not
also why wouldn't you take it if you're
lebron and
you're allowed to take it in the nba
right uh it's not that it's
allowed it's just they don't really test
for it
okay like like it's like i think they
test once a year like it's
an intelligence test at that point yeah
well well again we're doing these but
but it doesn't make you
less great yeah yeah yeah i mean the
guy's been doing pd's forever
but if i'm with lebron i'm 36 yeah and
because points and stuff like hgh
testosterone all that [ __ ] well it's
like even
even most people that would take it like
say someone takes the same thing he
takes
you're not gonna be like you're not
gonna be lebron james right same
argument with barry bonds yeah
yeah everyone shouldn't be in the hall
of fame you [ __ ] idiots
yeah oh because he took rights correct
yeah yeah but also
the pitchers pitching them were also on
pd's yes so yeah
so they're throwing 100 miles per hour
it's like was he killing it before he
was on it yes
now he wasn't killing like he was on it
well he had to even
baller both of them were ballers before
they even started right but then
they became super human oh yeah they're
them sammy sosa
all the boys but it's same thing with
like lance armstrong yeah
he was racing against other dudes on
pd's livestream better
like he's just better at it he's better
and then you give him that it's like
lebron
it's stupid because every they you know
with lance armstrong they have to go all
the way to 15th place to find a guy who
didn't test positive for steroids really
to give him the award that's trash no
it's
you're in a field of pds and he's just
he's just better than him like if i
started taking that [ __ ] i don't think i
could be lebron james honestly i think
the guy
15 is a loser like why are you thinking
why you didn't catch up like everybody
else is doing that this guy
he's delayed he's late to the party so
mcgregor was taking him huh mark mcguire
a-rod
all those boys everyone takes pete jose
canseco
uh because i don't know baseball well
but are these guys still in the hall of
fame though
no no so when you get steroids and also
they won't let them in
bro and you're just so stupid well they
weren't the only ones taking it no god
no but also they saved baseball
like baseball became so big after that
think about all the endorsement money
the advertising the the the espn run
like
remember there's a home run like
homeowner clicker yeah like
not even home run derby they did the
home run derby but when they were
chasing greatness like they were going
like
uh so so take 53 uh yeah i would hit 54.
it was on
breaking news yeah mcguire hits 15. i
remember that i remember that uh
barry bonte it's 59. it was so big that
i heard about it i don't even know
so big baseball's just eating up all the
money yeah all the money
marking like a [ __ ] yeah then
when they tested hot they're like oh
they're out damn that's so trash they
say baseball yeah
we got to bring it back that's why i'm a
firm believer in just doing on the low
like i think these guys
they are yeah but all of them are but
i'm saying when we have
how often do they get tested again now
it's almost a test of intelligence
they don't have like usada like the
that's what i'm saying they got tested
like often
like nfl nba uh uh
all that and you know mlb it's a test of
intelligence
yeah also i found out hall of fame
shannon sharp they don't pay you that
you don't get paid for being in the hall
of fame
for what do you mean oh no you don't get
a like you're saying like a stipend yes
you're getting paid from the nfl a
yearly uh yearly
a monthly check depending how many years
you played what yeah oh i didn't know
that my bad
hall of fame give you like that like you
can venture off and get like what
business deals with these companies like
i mean if you're in the hall of fame
yeah you're a legend you're a legend
okay
yeah man well that's good i mean oh i
got the six hundred dollars last night
you got what 600 dollars from what oh
you know they sent us the stimulus check
who did oh you already got it yeah
trumper you got it yeah
i mean what happened to the two grand
well here's the thing
we're going back we're going back so
we're going to vote again all right so
if they it
passed the 2000 we get 1400. i'm
surprised you all didn't get that damn
you already got
they wired it they got that [ __ ] set up
ready to go have you gotten the stimulus
check before
yeah i got mine before wait did you get
the first one yeah i got the first one
okay but the second one did you get that
one no i didn't get a second
no now here's the thing and this is
where i got to get off topic for a
little bit bear with me while i
elaborate
um you say a lot you did it right
wait wait i feel like you threw an extra
m
you're like elaborate
let me go through my elaboration all
right
here's the thing man a stupendous
goddamn i just rolled it yeah it just
wrong
that knockout was stupid i was like hell
yeah that's a word
he's like you're right man right you're
right this is his interview with stupid
pendants right yeah you good
um laid on us okay cool right so you got
six hundred dollars six hundred dollars
nothing for anybody
i know it doesn't matter now this is
where my complaint is okay so you know
how the u.s treasury we got to go and
borrow money and we have these hearings
to vote for
american middle class to get two
thousand dollars which everyone's in
debt
right we're not working and you got to
use all these credit cards to get food
and stuff like that and i just work for
xbox
right and everyone we all play pay
income tax in here
right they tax exactly in california so
they took a tax i got my check
xbox took the income tax took half of
that right i'm not going to say that i'm
not going to say what they took but
took half of that and you explore you're
saying between your your federal taxes
and your state taxes
you should not half but about you should
have prices 40 percent
let's say and they obviously got paid
more but say they paid you a thousand
dollars you probably got six hundred
dollars
exactly yes but you see how easy it is
for them to take out my
money yes taxes exactly it's taxes yeah
i hope they're taking
that money that we spend and give to the
government for these other people
that like you know that's like putting
food on these tables like look how hard
it is to get two thousand dollars for
the middle class america they have to
vote
that's the problem like yeah i would
feel way better about get paying these
high california taxes if i knew what
they were going through exactly
no black white asian whatever if you if
you giving the money to people
in need i don't have any problems yeah
[Applause]
just like the poor like look at have you
been on the 101
lately there's like yeah there's like
one part of the 101 where it's just like
a [ __ ] community of like
just homeless homeless up to 101 yes
where not your area 101 my area what i'm
hoping
for he got real
wow man
you go right it gets a little dicey
hey it's so funny because that's true
but look at this look at me the 101 but
look at uh the west side like you know
chin just moved to the west side i told
it was when i first moved here everybody
wanted to be on the west side the west
side was the [ __ ] spot yeah and now
everyone's like jesus
christ because the homeless because
newsome and
these laws that they pass they push all
the homeless to the west side so if you
go down wilshire
like brentwood where it's like the most
expensive real estate in all the land
dude it's a [ __ ] camp of homeless
people really
i mean dude tent city so just yeah how
is that allowed
bro this is the laws that they pass like
yeah they're like
the police can't do much they can't push
them out now because of the laws
yeah but they're
they're taking you know two thousand
dollars it's hard to give the
middle class working american people and
we've been in this pandemic for a minute
but
that's all i had to elaborate i'm sorry
because i said i'm mad as hell xbox
collaboration
elaboration education yeah you know
you know also you know that makes sense
yeah they took a lot huh
and i'm very frugal with my money all
right i said that word are you a penny
pincher
no i'm not it's good to be it's getting
frugal yeah i'm very frugal because you
know it depends
wait wait what are you frugal no no no
no no no i think i don't care about the
wrong okay
holy boy for life yeah come on
let's make sure you're not disneyland
while it rains hard but yes carry on
with your room
we gotta get my man so so with your xbox
check i don't know how much it was 40
they took out but what's up with a new
ride
what do you mean oh we got to get you a
picture like brendan had on that uh
porsche
oh yeah yeah i'm not getting a porsche
i'm gonna get a tesla you don't have to
get
whoa that's that's that's your goals you
can get a tesla
test hold on let's talk about you
getting a tesla so you're getting a
tesla
you live in apartment yeah okay we can't
set up a charging station there
so now it's a tesla in my apartment
building that the guy like yeah
yep so now every you're not gonna charge
overnight you have to go
somewhere to charge it yeah because you
don't have to own a home to set up a
charging station
so now you have to go around finding
[ __ ] charging stations into a
stupid-ass tesla
do you ever think about that no i didn't
think about that first of all you ain't
got to call it stupid yeah well
i don't know i love elon musk i love
elon musk okay okay that's not fantastic
so you're not a fan of
okay all right let's put like this but i
own the cars
out of all the cars huh out of all the
cars tesla tesla
let me tell you this because it's
electric what's that i've never seen an
electric porsche
yeah i seen an electric i'm not in that
tax bracket yet brendan
i thought we're talking about goals here
are you gonna get the electric porch
yeah uh if i were to get an electric car
that'd be the one i get or the new
hummers electric the h
the new uh i need three hummers
ridiculous h3
malik i thought you wanted to get a bmw
yeah i wanted i saw
i like brendan's that m3 by the way i
don't have a bmw oh
wait wait me and brent wait timeout i
got to call jay out on this
so he listened to the last episode right
and he goes
it's funny how britney said yo he went
from a prius straight to a porsche out
of m6 before them
i know a sign went straight from prius
to portland
i came i came to l.a in an m6
oh a 2006
m6 got it 2006. yeah he said it was hard
too black on black
yeah he said he loved that was the first
like major purchase i got and you said
you went on a date and all the doors was
unlocked
my first day i went out with my wife all
the doors just flew open
really what did you believe i have no
idea how it ever happened couldn't do it
if you asked me to do it again
no idea everything her [ __ ] louis
vuitton bag was sitting in the front no
one [ __ ] with it
off main street in venice but you again
you everyone wants to live in the west
side everyone wants to live
oh yeah now you do that you do it now
please besides dicey
yeah so what happened to the we want to
know what happened to that being you
sold it i sold it yeah
i'm trying yeah i sold that yeah
well no it no [ __ ] no it went
uh before the m6 i had a hummer
h2 and i had a
challenger when the challengers first
came out of challenger
did you have the picture of the m6 bro
you said you got the type in two on six
m6
that thing was [ __ ] sick yeah yeah me
and me and jay was like
oh it's like that yeah it's that far
right one
right yeah that one the black one yeah
no black on black yeah
well that goes hard as [ __ ] they were
cool man i know
if he had a v10 in it it was sick you
suited up
um no oh okay that had a v10 it was it
was sick
your first big big car purchase yeah
yeah
yeah is that what you that's what you
were saying uh that m6 is a big purchase
because i paid uh all cash for it
that was a big purchase especially
especially being a [ __ ] ufc fighter
i can't believe people let me do that
that's a bad birthday
don't get a tesla is what he's saying
okay i didn't i'm saying if you live in
an apartment because you don't have a
charging station yeah
you just it's just one more hat it's a
hassle
what do you like well i like i like the
bmws i like small like fast cars
i got like i like coupes you know like a
two-seater because it's like yo can i
get a ride on like nice
i got like someone else with me you know
i mean i like that kind of car
yeah coops porsche careers are coop
that is true but again he's not in that
breakfast i know he is if you're in a
tesla you're in that bracket
you use [ __ ] koopa and that's the
thing about porsches they're [ __ ]
reliable as [ __ ]
they're dope they handle waybound and
teslas they're not going to be as fast
but also tesla's they eat gas they do it
they know they're flat sixes they get
great gas mileage oh [ __ ] yeah great gas
mileage
and elena and uh you trying to pay that
dog not yet hold up that's a brand
that's a brand new that's a 20 21 go to
like 911 and that's a convertible you
don't want to convert with this yo give
me like a 2016
let me see what two things no you know
even at 214.
all right let me just see
hold on oh [ __ ] okay
okay but i want to use one that's that's
brand new oh that's brand new
for what for 2014. yeah yeah
let's just do this yeah if you do that
show me the car i bet you get one
look at
again i would love something like that
scroll to grateful for it
i mean i bet i bet we could find one for
50. that would it
now we're talking you file one something
like 50 in my oh
shoot 56. we could easily do that
hey okay look i like this i like this i
like that black one okay
and the black real sick say list 2014
off the la but it's not the s though
and it has 50 000 miles on it that's
pretty good
50k comes with some miles
that's of course so we're not too
worried about it
i mean hey man
oh you know what you want if you want a
dope ride for a good price that's newer
too and has like great engine uh
engineering
mercedes they hold value like [ __ ]
but also terrible value
i'll talk about dope cars and they get
as soon as you drive a mercedes
lot unless it's a g wagon as soon as you
drive off a lot
cuts in half yeah half probably half but
you get like a new s-class [ __ ]
but but you could get a dope-ass e-class
you get a dope [ __ ]
there's a look we got options well i
don't like you like that big body you
like that
uh the the the uh was it the e63 amg is
ridiculous
easy that's a four door you got this but
if you like coop
what about an m4 i love what's talking
about the m4s as well two thousand yeah
like it's uh small small cars yeah he i
don't like small cars
why why not i don't know you have a hole
that the
the porsche is not a small car but hold
on it's not
like an m3 to me would be a small car a
m2 would be a small car
that's the same size they're not the
same size the chassis is bigger
it is yeah i don't really fit m3s listen
that porsche you got that's a small car
that's not a small car
okay wait time are you talking a small
car would be a boxster
okay yeah i guess m2 m3 m1 those are
smart
uh mini cooper a mini yes a little bit
mini cooper well
it was so much fun what happened to your
mini cooper uh can i meet you in a mini
cooper yeah i used to drive a mini
cooper when i first started working for
you guys and then i drove that until the
wheels fell off
they're dope right my body used and it
was fun
right oh [ __ ] first of all bmw makes
them
so much fun to drive it's like a really
fast go-kart that's great on gas and you
can park
anywhere in l.a
[Applause]
hey that was my mom first car a subaru
sti is dope
prelude we'll get you a soup subaru a
mini cooper's a dope ass right there's
one right across the street i'm not
being a cheap ass lease on one right now
you would you what are you yeah now
listen are any girls going to want to
[ __ ] you in that mini cooper
no again i don't care that looks
like the uk version of chapel yeah bruv
how many minutes yeah they're done mini
coopers are dope damn look we'll go to
that jay
just got rid of his he did he did not
tell me we was over here looking at cars
and stuff like that could be you you
couldn't imagine jay fitting in a mini
cooper
yeah like you're pretty spacious inside
they are if it's just you and maybe one
other person very spacious yeah
depending on the size of the other
person
we don't have a family malik so it's not
i mean who gives a [ __ ] yeah you're
right i want to enjoy life you're right
again i don't know those new corvettes
my friend got those that's a hundred
thousand dollar car um
you get an old z06 that'd be sick yeah i
looked at that those oh well that's like
72 000. okay
okay so the search dude the test is the
tesla
the tesla is affordable
50 000. no the ones the ones allen has
yeah are you talking about the two-door
we're talking about the coupe yeah the
two-door
the small ones they look like a
bumblebee these are stupid wait what no
i mean
what do they look like oh i'll show you
oh the roadster the roaster is that what
it's not
available this one's no way no not this
one again that's khalid that's brian's
i'm not
the the one before that jen look 30
000. yeah it's cheap we look trust me my
research show me the tesla it's a coop
you typed it in right now
hey we're going to get you a picture dog
i appreciate you man well no not no
that's not again a surprise oh wait look
look the
i supplement that with peanut butter
peanut butter falcon you call that a
peanut butter that's tesla that's that's
that's actually probably that ain't it
that's suv also the suv is cheap
uh-huh yep the suvs aren't bad yeah
they're cool
come on man sounds like a mix between
this and the car yeah
it's just like that yeah unless
something like that yes
hey you could buy uh they don't have
like i'm just saying you don't have a
charging station man
okay you're constantly searching around
you're right well i don't
i'll just drive to the podcast like
brian's asked to be like like
where yeah i'd be like i'm at this
charging station
and plus man you know i'm gonna start
working out now so i need a car they're
gonna gonna fit me yeah cause you know a
lot i ain't gonna lie i've been doing a
lot of back days
and my my girl over facetime she was
like is your back your back looked like
a racehorse
she never said that okay and why were
you face time with your girl
at the jim no she's at uh she's she's
still there yeah she's still god damn
how long is she gonna be yeah she comes
back when i come back oh yeah
yeah because she wants to spend time
with her family yeah no worries but i
have been in back days now now here's
i don't like how you said she has how
would she see your back because i walk
from when i walk around the house with
my shirt off right so i have a poster
oh you're like you posted the yeah and i
was sitting and i grabbed something i
was in the cabinet i grabbed my glass
she was like oh stay there i was like
what
what do you see [ __ ]
she was like do you have any pants on
she's like i see a racehorse now
now a lot of you have any pants on or
did you have pants on no i had these uh
these hands with the cheeks cut out
yeah so here's the thing so when i
grabbed it she was like oh my god
is that secretariat i was like nah she's
like
you guys having uh phone sex hell yeah
all right yeah
jacking up i'll be saying like girl i
can't wait to put this little boy in
this slide
okay calm down come on man don't hurt
him don't hurt her but i don't hurt him
but when she scream you think i'm hurt
oh cause you know the back the back the
back yeah
over this over the phone just over the
phone well i did it one time i was like
i cannot do this
phone sex yeah it was long time ago oh
you did an old like damn girl what you
wearing yeah
i'm sorry you're really breaking up one
more time
do it more time for daddy all she hears
is do it
daddy
that [ __ ]
bro the iphone was out he had the kids
right the cricket i was i was trapped
it's funny about you saying what you say
what you just said
would you wear it
you're the corner i'm actually in the
kitchen spot
it's always fun it's like this isn't
good my roommates are sleeping
let's just do this another time
my roommate just got home
anyways man you seem to do it well yeah
you doing on facetime on facetime man
yeah we try to keep the spice in there
hey yeah i'm working out man so you
trying to trying to give her something
to hold on to
yeah yeah you should be jacking off on
facetime huh who me yeah nah nah i'm
working out so she sees the progress
oh you're talking about working out now
you you off the the dragon nah nah we we
phone sexy
with me it lasts like two minutes i'm
like okay i'm bored right
yeah so i'm like yo let's see she
started giving me compliments i was like
okay she was like you're back i was like
yeah what about it
and she goes like yo is it american
pharaoh i was like yeah that's what they
call me not me the
the media right and she goes okay yeah
this this sexy toxic yeah
is that american-made yeah
i'm american hell yeah yeah
what else are you yeah it sounds like a
transformers fanfic
i know right that's what it sounds like
well well again again also i showed at
the top but she said she complimented
she was cause i had the shorts on
i mean i had like these so the phone sex
consists of her just giving you
confidence yeah it sounds like it's
right yeah you you don't say [ __ ] to her
don't you want me to say this or not
also she sounds real bad at uh sexy
talks yeah let me know
are you american uh yeah from new
orleans [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah you make a lot of points
i i mean yeah
yeah you make a lot of goals nine goals
you're scoring all them goals
still i got a set shot you and your girl
are just
they took half but i'm still good yeah
um no i say a lot to her i come in all
the time there you go bro she's six
figure queen
also i gotta be facetiming his girl
during the middle we'll be like
in the middle of a conversation like
hold on what's up girl
i won't leave the room nothing we're all
sitting there then we get all quite
wrong
he's awkward he's all i'm eating right
now
yeah we're just eating yeah i'm with the
fellas
justin hey look this is the funniest
we're in the green room no brandon about
to go on right now
no yeah i gotta bring him up i gotta i
got time now i get about 30 seconds
what's up
chappelle on this closing joke look i
got you guys
yo yo it's the funniest day when i
facetime and i'm in a group
and i'm like yeah i'm with the fellas
britney always give me the side eye like
this
i like to show my girl no what are you
doing it's just weird
awkward i was like yeah baby's me and
the fellas look
like my girl wants to face somebody uh
yeah i'll be back at the room in like
two hours
i mean new love oh by the way man oh
what i'll show
uh um they call me you know the love
doctor
so i've been like giving this guy advice
for since october and he's finally like
committing
and making that leap and uh i shared
that who's the
dumbass asking for advice well he's not
a dumb ass i mean
he's a dumbass what do you mean he
doesn't listen i helped
why would he go to you fred love advice
bro i'm i'm doing great i love you all
been cool
uh since october and now he's finally
fairly new
okay sober november december you know
well i mean i guess you do have some
bias
you know you're biased because you you
haven't known him that long i don't
haven't known him that long i'm not
biased but
at the same time i'm not biased on him
but like you have a sorry unbiased
opinion on outside relationships like
shouldn't he ask chappelle
or me who've been in longer
relationships
what about mine you're not that it's not
that long we met in july
that's not that long that's not that
long you're a warranty do a quarantine
you've been with this girl for a hot
second
i've been mine for it great can we all
agree that quarantine
right i guess thank you some years
like it can make it like island yeah
love island they'll be like
there's like two days in the house and
they'll be like i don't know man i'm
just really into her brother
i'm like [ __ ] it's been two days but
they say like a day
and there's actually seven in the real
world yes so imagine what quarantine so
july i feel like man we already met the
parents we already met the folks so
like yo we sped it up so this guy in
october
he was going he was having problems with
his relationship i gave him some advice
i was like you know what i'm the love
doctor get on what was the advice
it was at the show yeah yeah at the show
the hammer guy i started clowning yeah
exactly
by the way i sent y'all to group chat i
was like yo our guy is finally doing it
brendan goes who the [ __ ] is that guy
i thought that was you're always
bringing dudes around yeah exactly and
then oh so
um he was like bro i'm finally going to
propose to her what do you think what
that was his advice i'm going to oh i
don't know yeah i didn't know you were
giving him advice well throughout the
year throughout the whole week we keep
in touch
you didn't share that in the tech in the
group text i did you just put
the message yeah but well i want you to
show there's no contact
okay okay okay so since october him and
his girl have been having like you know
problems and i said well what kind of
problems well just like
the arguments button heads they're
seeing being each other's way
and he lives in you know down there in
texas so it's open so i understand like
you're not having the same problems that
we're having in l.a
so i said well what's the problem let's
let's talk about it what do you what is
you're not getting
what you're not communicating well with
her for a second
how do you have time to deal with this
guy's [ __ ] problems
how do you have all this time to deal
with this dude's
relationship problems well they come to
me brenner
and you just take the time to deal with
it yeah like listen if any fans are
having like are y'all
y'all want to come to me i will give you
all that i would absolutely not
absolutely not never never i would never
okay so i love you to death so hold on
right or die
no no no not for no what the [ __ ]
i know how to score goals i'm gonna on
the stop sign with a girl with a basket
now he came because he was having
problems and what advice did you give
him i said listen you gotta understand
you gotta communicate with her
you can't communicate with me because
i'm not your partner okay you gotta
you dummy i told you that again it
doesn't matter it's not it's not the
messenger it's the message
correct plagiarizing his advice you took
his advice and put it on this poor kid
well
what the [ __ ] what am i supposed to do
it's great advice yeah that's fine
that's right
he didn't actually so don't don't shoot
the messenger yeah thank you
all right didn't mean to call you a
dummy you're really intelligent well
goddamn
so okay so you're helping so you said
open
what do we know about the girl though
okay i i asked him i was like yo
what is what is what does she do that
annoys you now just for the listeners
this is all i know of this gentleman
okay came to the show
white girl wasted yeah was it what was
in a jersey with no shirt on
underneath it was just changed it was
your journey so i started making fun of
him
and now he was loud yeah he was loud he
started heckling
he got roasted and then i think they
exco they they took him out right his
girl was embarrassed
oh they got kicked out of the show he
got kicked out his girl was like oh my
gosh she had to do a little thing where
she just leave
yeah yeah like that so when they get
outside i'm like bro calm down
relax you went outside well i was
already outside because jake me and jay
was setting up merch
okay so they was like what's going on
all right so he comes outside he's like
man all drunk i was like bro
use your words you're slurring yeah
right elaborate enough see it
right enough yeah so i'm like yo bro
what are you saying don't say a nausea
because because that's the problem
because you're trying to help this guy
yeah you struggle with the english
language yourself
you know what i'm saying well a lot of
people say gibberish or you know i
i i i speak three different languages
people don't understand that
okay so you see him wasting with his
girl outside yeah okay so
he comes and he's like bro you know i'm
just doing i'm not trying to have a good
time
i'm a girl with me i said where's your
girl three seconds later she comes out
diaz yeah she you seen her i'll show you
a picture i don't remember okay
well she's like she has this country
accent get the [ __ ] out of here now
but she's not a white girl she's black
that's what threw me off hell yeah i was
like okay well i never seen that that's
unique
who are you so i talked i was like baby
calm down tell me you call her baby
you know well no i mean like well i
don't think i said bad
sweetheart or something like that
because you is respectful
it was big it was like i would have said
country queen calm down
country queen okay well listen now now
let's now let's be
crystal clear for the listeners one of
the reasons you're putting so much
energy into these people oh yeah yeah
because he pulled up in a lamborghini
you gotta tell the backstory yes
continue well that's true
but also i'm in a row like he had a
rolex
inspired me now here's the thing and now
a few of our friends in the group are
thinking about jacking them
now carry on
we roll some thugs don't say that
okay cool so also i'm doing it because
you have customers
buying merch so you don't want to like
have this commotion
around why you making money so i'm
thinking about the business side of
things correct yeah so
i said bro it was a heckling during the
show and got lit up
you didn't carry on okay you're right
you're right and they said if you're
gonna be white girl wasted
yeah i don't want you wearing my either
way so we have paying customers right
now i'm looking at the consumer
standpoint
right this guy's yelling she's yelling
at him right now i'm trying to just buy
merch
[ __ ] up the vibe [ __ ] up the vibe
and jay jay right there he's like
handling business i said let me just
take this upon myself
let's go to the side and let me
de-escalate the situation there we go
okay so
i said talk in front of your lamborghini
okay well
again i i saw the keys he didn't give it
to me she had it she took it from her so
she was sober
she was sober and upset but she's
yelling and again you have pancakes
because she's making an [ __ ]
yeah she was like you're embarrassed
fair point by her now he's and he's
i was like bro what's your problem he's
like bro i never have a good time
i'm this my first time having a good
time but when i want to have a good time
i have to bring my girl
when i heard that that was a problem in
front of her yes
she got pissed i was like sweetie he
didn't mean that yes he did because he
said it i was like okay that is true
he did say it but he is drunk but also
the truth comes out while you're drawing
but also it's the truth homeboy suffers
from some problems correct me if i'm
wrong
yeah uh he comes from a rich family yes
and i
and i that's why sounds like bro you
come from a rich family you're trying to
find your own identity all right hit him
with that
because his daddy has some business so
he oil money
there you go and that money is long that
money is like i was like let's start you
got to find your own identity you got to
see who you are as a man
and grow into that in a prison does he
not have a job nah he
he's a i mean no all he does he listens
to podcasts works out
and deals with her i said bro what do
you like to do for fun
right you're not athletic let's just get
that out the way cuz look i'm looking at
my triceps and yours
not working it's not working because i
do not match i do a lot of these
yeah so he told me he's an athlete and
what do you say okay so he was like bro
i don't know i just feel like i'm living
for her
she was like you're not living for me i
said hold on let him talk first she was
like i can't believe you did all this
yeah i know this is exhausting i'm
already out
where were you oh you was on stage you
was in the back my bad i apologize
keep going okay so but from that
situation yeah yeah so you guys bonded
over that okay so i'm assuming you flew
back to l.a he stayed there
yeah you guys kept dming each other
correct correct
and he'll just now you have his number
now you guys are bros now now here's the
thing i told him quit drinking
right quit drinking yeah quit drinking i
don't know if he has to quit quit
drinking the reason
why alcohol listen he has a problem with
his girl
and alcohol seems to be the solution
that should not be your solution of the
relationship
you shouldn't have to go yeah i'm i'm
hitting them with some good [ __ ]
i'm getting them i'm hitting them with
some good [ __ ] it's the time to play
dummy is the time to play
you know act yourself so i'm like bro
listen it's not good for your health
go work out go lose weight go go back to
getting
to what you enjoy and she'll appreciate
you and he wants to come bro
now he's about to propose i i don't know
if that's the smart choice
is she into him yes
he listen the guy is working out now he
lost i hope he didn't ruin the proposal
by the way oh [ __ ]
um give him a heads up this girl listen
to the show well i think so because she
was like yo
i'm one of his best friends so i'm like
yo this guy and i'm i'm in a
relationship
i i'm pretty sure i'm probably gonna be
like one of the best men i'll fly down
there and
i mean he'll fly book my flight and i'll
probably go down there but uh
you would go down for it i mean yeah
come on you meant you i invested
real i told my girl good for unreal i
told my girl about it and all that she
was like bro you're gonna leave this one
go together
yeah that's what i'm saying i was able
to fly me and my queen up but uh uh he's
like yeah he would definitely do it
or money again and um he yeah he's he's
happy he's about to propose
again it's all because of your great
advice but how do you but how we know
him and this girl doing saul now where
they should be getting married well but
throughout the month so
this this was like early october how did
you did you talk about a prenup
because papa comes for money i know he
comes from family major issues i hear
those
don't really work like that in texas
uh because i heard like because i heard
well i heard
a woman from one of my homies that
did that he said um a woman could say
she signed that out of distress and that
could get it but they only work in
certain states though i heard about that
as well like they need a prenup you
happen to
i mean you can bleed i mean pre-nups are
for a reason but
but but uh a prenup you're still gonna
pay regardless if you're in a
relationship
even with the prenup yeah yeah yeah but
but it's it's there's a
the prenup skid's gonna you both come to
agreement on how much you're gonna pay
[ __ ] yeah up there but why does why does
someone have to pay
if you're splitting well i mean oh
because you
you're uh the joint earnings or i mean i
guess yes yeah
jointed yep [ __ ] okay
i don't know california is brutal yeah i
don't know too much about that situation
so i stay out of it but i just know
the prenup i don't know i don't know
that man affairs i'm not even in the
pockets but
you kind of are though and you gave them
information and you didn't even consider
it
and homeboy comes from serious money yes
a lot well also
they have major issues well well if he
looks you're at a show a few months ago
and they were
fighting like cats and dogs well we got
you've talked them into proposing to
this girl for the audience
the guy is only 26 right so we're kind
of in the same age bracket and he's like
a shitload of money
the girl is 27 i think 27.
does she have a job uh no she doesn't
have a job
so this guy is i want to get married
dude you would not
you wouldn't do it no hell no but
they've been together for a while
and now they're working through the
problems she's been now you're getting
married
but i don't think i don't you know what
i i don't think maybe i don't think
she doesn't answer yeah not yet not yet
only because yeah like if they're just
starting to now work it out like what's
that
let it work and like let it grow they've
been getting been there
because now you're doing a new thing
yeah when you're working what's the rush
well his point of getting married well
he thought that she was only with him
because of his money yeah
right and he'd be correct which is fair
well how we know that
how's that not fair how do you not know
i think that's fair to say but i don't
think it's correct yeah
so so wait wait i got you come from
money right let's put it i gotta
come from i know i'm saying you have
money i'm sorry hypothetically right you
meet a girl with a
of course hypothetically right you meet
a girl you have money
of course when you start vibing you like
man she only went me for
my money right so then you naturally you
had that in the back of your mind
so he had that to do now you have to
open are you with your six figure queen
cause cause love is tight love is
gangster all right all right come on
hey yeah and also we i didn't know i was
with her and i didn't know she was
before she
didn't know that was the thing yeah i
found she's very modest
she's very modest yeah she's in the
apartment she's very modest bro lately
how much does she makes
yeah well it's not a bad apartment it's
not a bad apartment but i'm just saying
for like if i had that much money yeah
you wouldn't be living there no yeah
that's fair
okay well i like it your new place is
tight though yeah yeah
he dropped me off in the small car and
now he's saying that point
thank you and that porsche she says it's
a big car i wouldn't be confused
that'd be like bro
though bro we was like like a boxster
a m1 a mini cooper those are the cheeks
this one [ __ ] grabbed me in the car
all right listen
he was like it's a race car he didn't
hear him
i don't even have to reach that far
actually yeah but the
the the fact that people have money and
you meet a girl that's very ordinary
naturally in the backyard is she
ordinary she's a baddie she's a baddie
but of course he's not he's not brad
pitt
okay listen to her she he may be
anything about that you're changing this
dude's life exactly listen
i just think it's a bad idea what's his
name don't give me his last name i can't
what's his name larry let's just say for
the sake yes larry
larry take your time dude if you think
homegirl is with you for money
definitely don't get married mm-hmm
no that wasn't i just don't think and if
you just got over the hump i mean why
rush well i don't i don't i i don't
understand the point of getting married
yeah what's the point for him at 27
26 but i think that it when you first
once you find your love like what's
what's the point why not
if you find like love right there like
why don't you get married
huh yeah take your own advice get
married i'm not in financial you know
your gun no
uh what do you mean being married have
to do with financial it has everything
to do
i want to provide i want to be the head
of the household well not really i just
want to provide
be a provider right and right now i'm
not in a position that i can't provide
for me
and my other significant or a family if
i want to start in that matter
but i'm saying this guy has all the
fortune right
he's in a great space space of life he's
happy she makes him happy
why not get on how can he say he's in
great spot of life when he came to you
you don't know each other he came to you
yeah
[ __ ] alcoholic yeah demons not
working out
no drive no desire doesn't know what he
wants to do
not working out start working out a
month
a month and a half but also because he's
a fan of you right yeah
that could that could that could help it
that could make it he didn't help him
i'm just saying i don't know if he's
ready to be like oh i'm saved
yeah like a month and a half later yeah
well all
right okay okay i hear what you're
saying i just i i i think
i think i took the i took the advice of
this travel the world with it
right and then when you feel like how
that trip goes you trust your heart you
still want to
get on the knee you get on the knee he
said okay great and i disagree with
travel the world that ain't real trout
in the world it's not real that's that
love island [ __ ] because as soon as you
get out of love island you're not living
in that
[ __ ] 22 million dollar mansion
getting food and you're doing all these
fun activities or in the bachelorette
you're on dates and [ __ ] pairs and
[ __ ] like that and then you're living in
austin a two-bedroom apartment that's
real but but he's got other shits not
really
he had his real life is love island he
has a 22 million dollar mansion so
traveling in the world staying up in a
hotel
that's not real though if she if she
only wants to be with you because you're
traveling the world that
that's not good no but she can't just
chill the [ __ ] out at your crib
they're on sunday yeah they're on good
terms they're on good terms doing
that right now like everything is mesh
and everything is jelly
i'm saying they should give that more
time yeah because it was
but they've been doing that before but
he just had this again he came to me in
a vulnerable state
right i said that right okay i'm rushing
my work vulnerable statement right go go
i don't know
i'm about to make a goddamn point don't
try to pity me now
i'm gonna roll this
what i'm saying the guy didn't know me
from a can of paint and i
you know for him to just expressing
himself i'm a can of paint what are you
55 years old what a weird reference i'm
country i'm country i've got you
ridiculous i'm over here queen
boy no carrot go i want to interrupt
i listen before the record i don't think
they should get married right now okay i
don't see the point of rushing it
well actually to travel around the world
at four seasons flying first class or
private what the [ __ ] he's doing
probably isn't the best advice either we
carry on okay
well working out not drinking sure
that's yes
he's uh can we all just started that he
he's a month and a half into it
it's a new year new celebration new life
new year doesn't mean
[ __ ] you're right you're right i i hear
what you're saying but you
dedication means everything this guy's
been dedicated for a month and a half
and six weeks and he's been
communicating what
six weeks you understand we've been in
quarantine for
eight months so again six weeks is not
the regular six weeks
that's all i'm saying monday sunday
through sunday
you know what i mean look at cat what
you thinking yeah
i just i don't see the point in like
doing all that just like
because i was with my ex for nine years
and we were struggling like the last
two years like we stuck it out for two
years struggling really hard
but it's just crazy to me that you think
after a month and a half of trying and
things are finally going good which is
great for him
which is great for him but like marriage
is not an end-all be-all you don't just
get married and suddenly everything is
fixed and everything
he does he wants to get they were
together y'all missing a point
they've been going through for like
seven years yeah they're together for
seven years but what's the rush for
to get married well because they already
get married it's gonna solve his
it's not solving anything but i don't
know why so you're saying you shouldn't
he shouldn't give married the absolutely
everyone everyone's
i don't think so yeah i'm not saying he
should never yeah i don't think so yeah
i'd be like hey let's write out this
song i think you give him advice get
mary's terrible
i didn't get what i actually i was like
bro trust yo you told her to do it
you said propose your girlfriend fly
i said bro trust your heart yeah i'm
happy for you i've been investing in
your relationship for
what two months now i mean three months
so i'm saying this
you're on the right path if you if you
don't want to rush it don't rush you who
am i to tell you don't rush what you
want to do
this is your life who's going to do what
it is he's going to do whatever you want
to do so
or not or he's looking for you for
advice and you're being like yeah
do it no i'm not saying it like that i
gave him real advice i was like bro
i'm loving the man you becoming i'm
pretty sure you are as well and she
loving the man you're for coming weird
you guys are a little odd yeah
you having problems i'm open listen g i
i love it because it's all with great
intentions yeah
it's not even like this is all like bad
[ __ ] it's all a great intention thank
you and i'm really i really
like listen we met again he was
intoxicating a hundred percent but the
sober guy
he's been sober he's a chill dude i get
it no dudes around i won't bring them
but i'm saying i'm saying this like i
build up a history with this guy
and i think he's a great guy yeah that's
all right okay you guys should have a
prenup of your friends
you should leave that
we'll start right there all i'm saying
is this brendan um
the guy is is i'm i'm all i'm all for if
you want to change your life around you
listen
you had demons you faced those demons
and look at you excelling today yeah
now should he get married and [ __ ]
you know
but at his whatever he wants to do let
him you always tell me i should get
married
you're different i don't know this this
oh yeah
i don't know this
[Applause]
i you guys are great
you get married like if you were a stock
i would invest in
the chappelle and what's your girl's
name i don't say here today but yeah
yeah i would invest in that stock
i don't know the guy who got lit up at
my show that i roasted for being
hammered in a
sleeveless jersey and changed your
jersey again it was the shot
now i'm sure he's a great guy but i
don't know him yeah yeah
okay so [ __ ] funny well i do
brilliant um and baseball hold up
you don't know him okay guys
you guys okay you guys are pen pals i
think that's good there's a pen pen pals
for sure
i i okay whatever y'all hung out
since the show and he's coming to the
same market
the next night no you know he wanted to
i told him bro just relax
you remember because he was going to
drive up in the lambo and i was like nah
just now
now maybe if he comes and he's sober
he'll be a great guy he's a great you
bring him around yeah you'll see
airbnb do not bring him to the airbnb
so he knows where we live i'm not going
to bring him to the airbnb but he's
coming to both shows by the way both
shows okay in san francisco yeah friday
saturday uh yes
he died 29th and 30th yep oh god now
exactly any dollar he loved the
little sean this is about on all
platforms by the way if y'all want to
listen to that
and uh he he he's like bro i support the
show i support what y'all have going
i appreciate that and i was like bro
i'll pre i support your relationship
in return i support you right so any
problems you have
let me know so he just you're a good guy
he's a good guy so he offered a good guy
is that what you're looking for here no
yeah what are you looking for i'm not
looking i'm not looking for
anything i'm just saying i didn't i in
grade attend i told the guy look
do what you feel right that's what i
want the audience to know i didn't tell
a guy to get married
i just said he's like bro i'm thinking
about proposing okay cool do what you
feel whatever so
this is larry i'm from my experience i'm
telling you proposing is
not the best option chill
work on the relationship and then if
it's going good in say a year from now
then do it there's no rush man yeah
because also
when you get married nothing trust your
boy nothing changes the government goes
yep you guys love each other and you go
thanks man if we decide to separate you
get half my [ __ ]
yeah that's all marriage nothing changes
so
do you do you feel they live together
yes do you feel like with this situation
you become a
uh love guru no the love the love doctor
love doctor get on out of here martin
lawrence so you think you think you
have pretty knowledgeable winning yeah
because it takes two to tango
okay so so you've been with your girl
for how long
again july but in quarantine years it
felt like you got to quit these
quarantine years you've been with us
since
july yeah how long you been with your
girl uh
two plus yeah strong
strong yeah and and honestly i admired
that i admire everyone's work and if i
have to invest in relation
if you if two of you if your
relationships are stocked yeah
i'm buying chappelle stop what about
money so he should ask chappelle
wait wait what mine is listen you might
just you know mine is thriving though if
we want to up
you invest in it when it's new it's easy
again quarantine's been tough on a lot
of relationships
like it's been time we we together we
spent a lot of time together
like a lot of time so i i get happy
while i'm on the road i'm like i get to
see the fellas but we get
we spend a lot of time because it's new
so you know so you pick
you you learn stuff faster that you
wouldn't normally do in quarantine
because it's
everything is closed so what do we do we
go to each other house right
and we learn little stuff that bothered
me i would have not known
in like let's say two years down the
line like a little she has had
probably you said you would have found
out i would have found it she has hair
all over the place
i'm like freaking from her hair yeah
from her hair she's she's losing hair
no no no she's just like having long
hair and it's like all over the place
it's girls yeah yeah exactly but i was
like
but listen i go to her house it's you
know on the rug it's hair i'm like yo i
again i appreciate the long hair i love
looking at your long hair i just like
looking at it on you
not on the floor but she can't help it
for her no no no he said again she's
going
no she's not going bald brendan but when
she comes over those girls hairs just do
that like it just
yeah yeah yeah but it's so much hair but
like
my hair is longer too i found a hair
today i'm like goddamn like every time
you comb it out yeah it comes out
it's just yeah but it's all over the
carpet all over but that does she not
clean it
no no because she's she claimed listen
her name right
you know i [ __ ] that one now you said
you
said she wasn't losing her head with his
hair all over the room
chappelle's girl's hair comes out and
all over the rug it's all over me
i can still wear black yeah it's not all
over my [ __ ] pants
again i just said hair that bugs me and
again well that means all girls would
bug you yeah no no no [ __ ] up right
i'm saying yo you know what i mean
listen i don't all girls here comes out
unless
it's a blackberry your hair is not your
hair your hair's not all over the place
is it
it can if you don't vacuum that's the
only thing you're not cleaning up after
yourself
that's what i'm saying here she's messy
she's not messy it's clean she's ocd
it's not clean though if there's hair oh
there's a rug there's some [ __ ] going on
there in the bathroom
and it's wool looking pretty good
if there's hair all over that's maybe
maybe you should not clean it a lot
let's talk about your relationship hold
on what no she's not dirty are you dirty
i'm not
ocd like honestly i must have ocd if
here bothered you
yeah but again i cleaned up after but
i'm saying
that nags me and we talked about it i
was like hey listen can you just be
conscious
and aware what can she do her [ __ ]
hair's falling
that's what bro i'm not i'm not trying
to change her i'm just saying like just
can't because it's like that bothers you
it just bothers you but what can she do
i guess vacuum more
yeah that's it that's it and i honestly
i take the integrity and i just like
the initiative i should say i take the
initiative to just like vacuum her place
i do stuff like that she comes over i
listen we're great brendan
i'm gonna love doctor get on out of here
now i'm just saying do you all say the l
word
y'all say y'all love you nah nah never
done that yet not yet
yeah well but what happened you guys in
quarantine
where you at now you're like [ __ ] up
i thought courtney spat everything i
mean when he said you say the l word you
were oh no
it's not get crazy now it's hard i'm
gonna love doctor but hey now let's get
all right no i mean i think it's more
you see yourself saying it yeah but i
think it's more for her
then then i think i slipped up and said
girl i love you
and then she came back she was in the
bathroom she was like she walked him out
you love me
she like what you say her hair coming
out
for promo code
although said it yeah but i think it's
more for her like me saying it to her
and uh
what do you mean like like i said over
new year's like we hung uh like hey you
know you gonna say it i'll say it on new
year's eve hey come on man wait did she
watch this are you gonna spoil it for
her
nah she don't watch she she gave up that
don't watch girls you shouldn't watch
does your girl watch this show no she'll
watch anything i do no
yeah they shouldn't it's not like she
this how she and she gets mad at me like
i watch the news and try to like study
and research for like a current event
and all that
instead of spending time with her she's
like oh you on your podcast [ __ ] i was
like okay just relax i'm still trying to
educate myself
you mean just that you're watching the
news yeah watching because she knows the
reason why
she
heard you arguing before when in the
airbnb i heard you arguing
are you oh yeah what's your job what
city what city
i mean name a city i know right we've
been doing a lot of them
but now wait wait wait i've heard jar
you before with her yeah
like she's tripping blah blah blah oh
well that's a little important because
again that's not an argument that's me
expressing what i can't say
i'm like man this girl is tripping yeah
right because
she's not getting it so i i need her she
needs a moment didn't she
get it like just a little stuff like
okay the podcast situation right
when i did the whole this shot little
shine and stuff like that
clearly it's for entertainment it's this
whole persona rollerboard yeah she
thought it was deep because
she was like oh you still caught up on
your ex i said whoa let's not let's not
do it yeah yeah
let's not do that because yeah everyone
girl but but
she did sometimes it just takes her a
while to process that
so that's why i was like bro if you're
gonna do this sweetie don't watch it at
all so she
is instead of like to avoid the argument
she won't watch it at all yeah
have you have you and stevie ever got an
argument over anything on shows
uh no not on shows usually i fought with
him a lot when we first started dating
oh about what
because i used to think he was so
sketchy based off the way you guys talk
to each other like i wanna yeah i wanted
nothing to do with stevie when i first
met him
yeah yeah i mean yeah he did seven years
of hard time yeah yeah
i wanted nothing to do with him and he
kept hitting on me and i was like okay
maybe i'll like get to know this guy and
i used to fight with him all the time
about
random [ __ ] cuz i thought he was sketchy
as [ __ ] i thought he was out here
like on some [ __ ] [ __ ] i thought he was
a [ __ ] boy no
yeah and then like i got to know him
like oh like you work out all day and go
to like home depot to do diy projects
yeah that's all he does i don't really
help you fight with him
it's actually nothing over the show
nothing right he could have been oh you
could have helped that out
alex said he could have helped you all
out
no i think it's just one of those things
like i don't think i would have believed
anybody unless i saw it myself because
you guys are all boys
that's true that is that is very scary
yes
actually i would have listened to
brendan though brendan always has like
my best interest
he always gives me a heads up yo listen
he talks all the time i agree with my
older brother
i want to go back to your girl losing
her hair
you said now you said this do you think
it is why is your stress
why she's going bald no she's not he's
trying to he's trying to get down or
something what are you trying to get at
again my girl
wheels on facetime worried about her
hairs all over the place okay
that's the things that nag me again
we're in great space literally i
facetimed
what else but what else that but i mean
the hairs whatever
she could she can't control it what else
um not too much i mean she called me her
little jaguar i was like yeah cause
you're a jackpot
yeah yeah you ever seen like a jaguar
she called you that's her pet name for
you jaguar jaguar
it's french jaguar hmm
yeah jaguar yeah yeah what why are you
making
what would uh nags her about you uh i
think that i'm
constantly on my phone remember that
thanksgiving that thanksgiving
i'm with her you know what's funny is
you text the group chat you went
dude my girl tripping because i'm on my
phone and all of a sudden
dude yeah i remember that you're on your
phone a lot
yeah well again even around us you're on
your phone a lot i'm the love group i'm
the love doctor i mean
he's out there helping i'm helping
people you scroll on the ground
yeah but and what happened when remember
when we looked on the phone and can says
what you're looking at
yeah remember when we did that we did
that and my social media was through to
the right
it was it was like the social media bar
was like so if you have an iphone
oh like yeah iphone sunday weekly
relativity yeah
yeah yeah your weekly activity and mom
was through the roof but uh
nah that's the only thing like being on
my phone but i'm always present
she tells me story and here's the thing
let's listen to her stories now
women tell stories and we can all be
honest stupid stories okay i didn't want
to say
thank you just a comment story for you
cat
that's a little different oh she's a
homie yeah but i'm saying your girl
and she is a business woman like she
works she's a producer
right and she like gets like and she's
in the entertainment field so i got to
hear about people i don't care about
but i'm i'm involved and i give her i
give her advice she says patrice o'neill
has the best joke about that by the way
about what uh who somebody got shot yeah
yeah
yeah who got shot
yeah yeah dude because she was trying to
tell them a story about gun or someone
got shot yeah but she never said it
yeah she would just go off about like
you know me my friend we don't like guns
we just think that yeah
who got shot did she get shot no she
gets shot
and why are you telling me does she
shoot somebody yeah
why are you talking because she don't
like guns oh it's one of the yeah
greatest business and i can relate
like but again but it goes to your
advice now three years down the line she
tells me that same story
i'm be tuning her out but right now it's
fresh i'm listening
but but again like i'm invested and
we're great so yeah
i'm present all the time she's just like
yo you on your phone a lot
jim what bothers you about your girl
look at looking pretty look at
this what is this out here
are you the love doctor nothing no
nothing nothing
when someone says that this is a show
that means no she doesn't listen to
anything i do at all the only time she
should
do it the only time she even knew
something was that freaking king and
sting thing with a date
and that was that was she mad at carl
she got hurt yeah
why oh because you were together and
went on that date and i was you know i
was
going around you were with your
girlfriend and you drank all that sake
and i was playing around with a big tip
exactly you know this is gonna happen
i'm gonna make it like as fun as
possible
energy was upset entertainment that's
kind of yeah that's validated yeah
probably i couldn't help that but
there's nothing that that she does that
just pissed you off i think i told you
guys at
in nashville didn't i no yeah you told
me oh
african-americans she's playing a bunch
of activities like uh
didn't you go through the slaves the
cupcakes as well
you made uh old-fashioned yeah i mean
that didn't bother me
it's just i don't know i'm definitely
going to say it
i don't know i just watch it but i'm for
whatever reason whenever i talked about
someone before like someone knew someone
that knew someone that knew someone and
then they found out
yeah mm-hmm oh we edited this i don't
know
what do you think uh bothers her about
you
um well you know i drink every day
that bothers her you don't get i've
never seen you i don't get drunk but
then
of course you know now that she's around
me more often it does feel like do you
have to drink today and i'm like yeah my
girl does that oh yeah but i want to
relax and
chill hates my drinking hates it so
that's one thing
yeah just like you're getting another
you only you you only do it at night
when it's like winding down right every
night for the most part at night time
but then we've done it here like i'll do
it
i'll do it here every now and then like
if i don't pick up my son from school i
drink
or at night i usually have a drink i'm
taking january
off yeah wow until san marcos
but i think that's stealing but that's
the end of january oh but
i mean that's pretty but i mean
everything that she doesn't relax yeah
everything that she doesn't
agree with with me i think that's valid
the drinking
she's just worried about your health be
healthier yeah yeah but i'm like yeah
otherwise i'm i treat you you are a
pretty healthy guy
yeah overall i would say you sardines
right sardines they're right there
yeah does your girl you i mean you guys
are pretty solid anyway
you don't do i mean what do you do
you know like what would you do that
piss her off i don't know i don't do
anything
i know you just kind of chill yeah i
mean the only thing uh
i think at first like she was just
asking a lot about because i have a lot
of
uh friends that are girls from
cheerleaders so she would ask about them
a lot but i'm like
if you understand they're smoking yeah
they're really hot she's like
she's like why are all of them hot yeah
i go there i don't [ __ ] know you know
i mean that's just how they are but like
i'm like you have the hottest friends in
the world i know i do
and they come to the christ shows your
friend i'll help you out hey
this guy bought two shirts dude he
wanted to meet you
get out of here i bet i apologize he's
gonna fly to palm beach man
i did do that i followed you these guys
man i'm checking can you sign his shirts
i did i'll never forget i said hey
brittany this guy wants you to sign up
what are you doing dude that would be
tough for your girl yeah that was yeah
which initially
yeah of course but like i was like well
would you be cool with her if she had a
bunch of hot guy friends
i mean yeah go for it really yeah like i
mean because
i mean the thing is it's like what
they're gonna cheat they're gonna cheat
it would already happen yeah you know
i've known these i've known them for
years like since we were like 15 years
old so it's it's a different case and
like
when she meets them i'm like you just
got to meet him and when she meets them
she's
totally fine she's like oh okay she's
like she's because you you would see the
vibe if it was there
sure it would have dude it would have
already happened yeah you know that's
good but
but i i respect that you know she did
bring it to my attention i respect that
she actually told me
instead of just like being quiet about
it yeah and just being like why
you know like just you know being snarky
about it and but she
communicated i guess uh with me on that
and it's like oh okay
like does your name explain your girl
come from a good family
yeah decent family yeah yeah yeah
not like i mean yeah yes yes mom and dad
are together
no they're not they haven't been
together for like years or whatever but
not the same background as you
no no no
yeah [ __ ] no that'd be tough i mean
interesting
i mean it is interesting i mean like
what do you do
yeah this [ __ ] asking everybody
i got a truck at you what do you do
i do that it's my girl what are you
doing
uh jeez where do i
start starting off tough to deal with
okay
um what do i do that pisses her off
nothing to me is a big deal
nothing oh you got it so you're very
nauseous so my son took on the same
kind of personality where he'll spill
something be like it's not a big deal
mom it's not a big deal because
to me nothing's a big deal yeah i'll
figure out whatever it is
drives are nuts i have a solution so
like whatever
you name something nothing like to me
nothing's a big deal
yeah everything i'll figure out and i'll
get over it yeah you're fine i don't
stay mad
ever i'll be mad for two minutes and i'm
over it yeah she'll stay mad
for three days i don't think i've ever
seen you like just like
pissed i'll get heated and then i'll
then i'll think about it and then i'll
get over well like i mean like a
consistent like
this whatever now she harps on the
situation and like
no she doesn't heart blinded she just
she is she's
because i'll say uh it's not a big deal
and it's triggering for her
oh got it yeah so it'd be like some
major [ __ ]
like her grandma passing away but it's
not a big deal i mean how old is she and
she'll be like she's like
90 i'm like that's what 90 that's what
90 year olds do
and she'll get super upset because she's
like oh you have no you know you have no
love for this or what i'm like but it's
like that's life like that's
the circle of life yeah 90 you're out
man
you get a good run
[Applause]
is good 90 years great run 90 years
great run now now now you said 90. you
chose that number we didn't ask it you
gave it to us
what is there any significance behind
the number 90 for you that means she's
old
that's 90. yeah that was a [ __ ] my
grandma i think's
98 98 oh damn congratulations 98
should be uh she might be 99 not in
shape
none shaped swims every day damn it but
like when she passes it's like
i wasn't that close to her but like my
dad would be like [ __ ] up about it but
like
what is your dad's mom yeah i probably
won't fly home to the
funeral you know like i missed my other
grandma who i was way closer with
i miss her funeral that's your mom's mom
yeah yeah like that stuff
that's not how this life dude damn
yeah i mean yeah that's what he's yeah
but other than that
nothing bothers me than that nothing now
now
that you're not you're not oh i'm messy
i'm real messy
but then this is uh you know what they
they surveyed like
g i'm not saying i'm a genius but this
is the excuse i give my girl
they surveyed geniuses from history like
the top smartest minds in the world
you know what they all had in common
they were messy unorganized
i'm messy yeah like i'll put my my shoes
everywhere my clothes everywhere my
drives my girl nuts
damn she has ocd she has a bad ocd
yeah like if i put like i'll use almond
milk for something and i'll put it
in the wrong spot she'll freak out oh
really i don't give a
[ __ ] see that dress drives her crazy
yeah that probably that'd probably drive
me again
yeah i put that right there uh
oh i'm not like with our kid she's super
disciplined i'm not
chill cool dad i'm the fun dad damn
bad cop good cop mm-hmm
damn uh-huh i like that look at he right
you can't have two bad cops you can't
you can't but also i'm like
he'll make a mistake and she'll get real
mad and then
uh he'll be like hey i'm gonna write uh
mama like a note saying sorry i'm like
yeah do that so i'll help him like draw
with him oh okay yeah and then he'll
give it to her and she still won't
she'll still hold the grudge oh she she
gets mad and i'll look at her be like
you're [ __ ] up
pondering on that situation yeah okay
all right
okay so two bet you can't have two bad
cops no good cop what else you got
well yeah look at this cool dude
okay cool dude that's an imperative
sentence um
no not because that's what i do he's in
the class right now so you know
so it's three things so you know like
should be real stressed and i think
she'll be mad
that i'm not more stressed like it'd be
chaos at home with you guys
yeah i'm pretty i'm like yeah she's like
can you want another one like i want two
more
she got the [ __ ] i'm like we'll figure
it out figure it out i was just worried
about it
over here don't figure it out there's
people with way less who figure it out
yeah
true yeah so it's not a set plan it's
just like go with the flow
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
okay are you trying to be love doctor to
this dude no no i'm just i'm just
grasping i'm just understanding the
situation now now
you said you said you said she's ocd and
you're a little messy now how long ago
i'm definitely messy how long have you
been messy my entire life entire life
now do you making a habit that like okay
my wife
no i don't care and that's oh now so it
goes back to the nonchalance
okay now how does she feel about that
how i'm nonchalant right yeah
oh drive's a nuts
i'm bringing it i'm bringing it i'm
breaking i'm breaking it down i'm
breaking it down now
come on now all right let's give you
these questions you have the floor okay
because these questions are in toronto
all right so listen
is that a is that a country i didn't say
in toronto
no this is getting in taragawa
all right what country is that yeah you
want to go where
you want to go you want to go it's your
hogwarts man
i'm trying to go there it's an island
this island dog come on i'm antigone
so you're saying here is you're you're
nonchalant
and she has ocd and you say you don't
care oh i'm also super protective of my
son
so she comes from the like her mom used
to spank her stuff
and like hit her yeah and she can't hit
tiger around me
yeah that won't happen yeah and that's
fair that's fair it won't happen that's
fair
okay okay so she's strict on discipline
super chat i like that i like that
now now here's the thing do you
agree you're a great dad great husband
but i'm i'm trying to dig deep a little
bit
go ahead man all right you said careful
what you find daddy
i'm very comfortable i'm very careful
you know i won't i won't waste a drop
let me just tell you something
so ugh
drop no no no yeah you ocd i mean you're
messing
your girl have the worst sexy talk of
all time is bad you're a new orleans fan
you think the saints are going to win
this division that is good
this is new for us like we you know
we're not not trying to find out about
it
yeah exactly keep going but let's go
back to you yeah yeah
oh she hates how uh keep getting the
shoes i have too much she's like we're
running out of room i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about oh i like
that she's
ocd and your shoes all over the place
and you're running out of room well
they're they're not that they're all
all over the place but when i get a new
pair of shoes just say are you gonna
throw some out like
no why would i throw them out no i
collect shoes
is she claustrophobic nope okay okay
okay any phobias she has what is he
getting it nope
no no phobias any phobias do you have
you're a terrible doctor right
no no this is this you gotta die no
phobias
no phobias okay so so so so you're messy
you have shoes everywhere if she's ocd
she cleans up
and y'all mesh your kids she's you're
not you're the cool dad she's very
protective mom strict she like to whip
her kids
because i mean she's never woke up she
never whipped them exactly special
friend you don't tolerate that
okay then you said then you also you
said um
tiger right this is um correct me if i'm
wrong
you said uh when they write letters she
ponder on situations too long she harps
on stuff too long right now does that
annoy you
uh yes it does okay now how do you
express that with her
i mean we just talk about dude you talk
what do you say i'm just if i'm your
wifey
you're brandon i'm i'm miss brendan's
shop go ahead over
what dude this is terrible over what
what do you mean i i don't like it
brendan i don't like it i just i tell
her she just needs to get over it but
i wouldn't i won't entertain it i don't
stay mad so she can stay mad i keep
going
so she's fuming yeah just like i power
through it like everything's all good
and she has no choice but to adapt to it
because the kids
you know they'll pick up on it
okay that's it
but i think her biggest problem today
i'm messy and and i do and i drink a lot
and remember when she mentions
her sober i didn't drink at all so when
like at night she like another drink
because there's alcohol uh issues in my
family so she's worried about that oh
god but she
she what i'm what i'm gaining from this
situation she's she know how to adapt
when y'all met you i know how to adapt
well yeah of course well because you're
fighting background and all that but
also you just give credit to your queen
because she knows the adapter as well
for sure you know also when she met me
we had a uh 300 square foot apartment
oh damn we're sleeping on the floor oh
yeah that's right and i only had an ipad
yeah that's how y'all watch tv yeah we
watch the same movie over and over
there that's some creed [ __ ] that's when
he was moving to philly he had to watch
like
any other movies but yeah ace ventura
some about mary oh [ __ ] happy gilmore
that's a good movie selection that's a
great movie all right
well good work man oh thank you was this
the love episode i don't want to
see i got a love absolutely i got pissed
what do you got dog
all right first one okay so in 2019 the
panthers tackle russell
o'conn tweeted that he wanted to get
paid in bitcoin
and this past week the owner of the the
owners of the panthers
uh agreed to give him half of his 13
million
salary in bitcoin interesting
he's the first person to get paid this
way good for him
do you see this as like a good thing or
a bad thing i see it as a great thing
i wonder if that counts towards the
salary cap because
i i don't i i feel like if they paid
them half of them bitcoin i bet it
doesn't go against the salary cap
hmm money is more than currency it's
power the way money is handled from
create
christian dismissal dissemination is
part of that power
yeah that's cool our stocks have been
going up like crazy too
yeah what'd you say their stocks bitcoin
bitcoin yeah
wow interesting that's pretty [ __ ]
dope then that's cool
that's pretty cool yeah how cool is that
how cool is that okay so i believe
it was last week or two weeks ago french
montana did a photo shoot for xxl
and if you scroll down this is what he
looked like yeah they're fake for sure
people are saying that he's sprinting on
to his i have a friend who's a high
profile photographer
for rappers and they have him editing
abs all the time
what rick ross says [ __ ] it
there's only so much we can do he's just
fat
like but yeah he responded saying that
he did not spray on his abs and that
he's just been working hard
because he had a incident where he had
to go to the hospital
doctor said he was drinking too much
taking too many pills so he
tried to turn his life around i know i
think he didn't owe d but he had an
issue with uh pills
play that video there nice rolex people
think oh no that looks real
people think it's sprayed on and he's
trying to come out and say that he's
just taking care of himself
you can spray on abs 300 did it but you
don't need to be
fit to a certain extent to have the abs
kind of to get the definition yeah
for sure i'm sure there's a little bulk
in all that
but the truth is somewhere in the middle
i get faced with those kind of problems
all the time
people think mine are fake they're real
but he used to have that
uh fat skinny build though fresh montana
did he was drinking a ton
especially in that pop that video he was
don't stop
that no great song that's a great song
are they also saying that
they're like implants or just those
sprayed on uh people
have been saying that they're sprayed on
maybe some people have been saying
possible implants but
you guys get light bone [ __ ] you do all
sorts of weird [ __ ] so
tuesday morning at 1 00 a.m
uh tyrese got back to his house in
atlanta
and parked his range rover in the
driveway he
then woke up at 8 am went outside and
noticed that his car was gone he called
the police and they had cctv from his
house
with four men in a sedan driving by
one guy comes out of the car gets into
his range rover drives off
off and tyrese ends up saying oh [ __ ] i
left my keys inside of the car oh wow
you know what
you know so dope about this story uh he
uh they caught the guys
he bailed all those guys out what yeah
he did wow
he did because he was like bro he's just
like you youngest man you know just stay
safe out here i get it
he left his keys i bet you don't [ __ ]
with him again
so no one [ __ ] yeah exactly so you
build them so dope
now that video that is not a land rover
that'd be a volvo
what video is this that's a vulnerable
concentrate i don't think that's his car
though i don't think so
right now not happy with the city's
response to crime in buckhead
this comes days after this shooting on
peach street i think something else yeah
it's covered in crime mm-hmm oh but yeah
that was dope of him
yeah keys in your car though yeah so
pope francis's instagram account strikes
again and was
caught liking another very scandalous
photo
of an ig model that other model yeah was
such a bad
yeah so this girl uh he liked a photo
on her account and people are saying
that it's his team he does not run
himself obviously
and that someone is in a lot of trouble
but
apparently she's making a bunch of money
now off of it oh
she also wanted to say that she herself
is
very religious and thought that this was
a a sign
from the good lord
for her to do what though yeah i guess
just uh
to keep doing her you know good nipples
interesting
so the the uh catholic priests aren't
allowed to like
do anything they can't have a
relationship no they're gonna be
celibate
celibate all that stuff right they can't
have any fun
i just want to know who is a part of
that team running that account
accidentally liking these folks
so stupid you know mormons have the same
um like they live by their strict
guidelines no no alcohol no smoking no
sex
like mormons but they're really no
mormons can have sex they have something
until you're married right yeah yeah but
i'm just saying no [ __ ] are you talking
about like uh like
like say you're a mormon in college
can't do anything
yeah i'm sorry go ahead i wonder if they
get around that
oh yeah anal i know that but i'm talking
about like
because i think i don't know like
[Laughter]
speaking of only fans diego sanchez
started his only fans account now do you
guys know who
david sanchez is no he's with his coach
that's his coach
he's on there too this is just a funny
picture that they had but oh
okay i'm about to say only fans is this
this is a funny picture yes
super clickbait but he did his coach is
that interesting
uh dude yeah very weird and you've been
nice you've been nice
but what's the only fan's account gonna
be it's his his coach doing things it's
him doing like martial arts stuff and
meditating
just like regular oh it's like another
videos and stuff
yeah just kind of like just random stuff
that you put right on patreon
exactly or even instagram yeah yeah they
did them wrong on that picture though
right all of the hotel room
smiles too close in the back
[Applause]
the first month he set up his only fans
with this photo
it popped off i think that this article
uh
modified yeah it's possible those are
two fake pictures it's just funny
oh yeah they're better in the back you
could tell by the drinks right yeah but
it looks like they could have posed
while working out
i don't think so you can't tell by the
drapes [ __ ] horrible pictures
that looks like after a fight at the
hotel doesn't it no it doesn't no it
doesn't it look it doesn't even look
like
a picture yeah that's a fake picture
once from one
from two different accounts and they
impose the the weird work my friend
that's weird all right the next one
billy eilish
i guess she posted some drawings of her
drawing boobs
and she lost i guess a hundred thousand
followers because of that well it's
because
on instagram right now there is a trend
where you'll go
and put a quest the one of the question
polls
up and she it says uh what do you want
to see
so you post you send me in what photo
you want to see from my camera roll and
i'll show you what it is so people will
say like
i want to see a photo of you and your
dog and then you post a photo of you and
your dog or it's like
uh you on december 1st
and you post that photo just to kind of
share memories your fans
probably didn't see a post of a picture
yeah a drawing out of your browser so
do this yeah and she says she likes
drawing boobs and she lost 100 000
followers
because she likes drawing boobs yeah
remembering super bad he liked drawing
dicks
oh yeah it was funny yeah that's her
response but y'all babies
shaking my head i'm with her yeah
it's on my page and bob would you
unfollow her yeah because she draws
boobs
by the way those drawings are pretty
great i like that yeah it's pretty good
and you guys were talking about this off
air these right
yeah yeah i missed it so they're
starting out 500 but i guess you can't
get them i took an l this morning
likewise
you guys think they're dope yeah yeah i
like okay i'll wear the shells
do you know they're going for like a
grand now though yeah
damn that was the first ever um
automatically automatically js they've
they've done them before
there's some mags the the mags automatic
lacing
there's another they're they're kind of
a version of the mags or automatic
lacing
they've done you can get you go to foot
locker and get automatic lacing uh nikes
right now right now but
the first were jordan's though first jc
yeah with the 11s as well yeah those are
sick i like those
yeah i took it l as well brendan so
you're not i i took yeah all sorts of
l's
damn all right cool though those are
cool mm-hmm
so i have an announcement to make jane
hold on wait tell me what
your girls pregnant no no no you're
getting married
no 11 no 11's but bernie we've been
working together for
how many years now since fox right yeah
i've been with you since fox five years
it's been a while yeah started blow the
belt king of the sting are you quitting
no what oh my god
you're cool you you're cool [ __ ] you
so you got to be better about those man
on purpose though but i got your gift
oh [ __ ] what up let's see what he
okay okay let's do the uh
oh [ __ ] please oh [ __ ] pl please don't
be a guitar please be a peanut butter
yeah damn let's see what he's got oh
damn you got him a martin oh my gosh
martin dreadnought
dude this is beautiful i don't know well
now now i gotta learn to play the game
oh damn thanks brother
yeah man awkward hug
brendan doesn't hug that's why i'm like
yeah yeah i've never seen brandon
now yeah i learned to play the [ __ ]
guitar no choice now
let's tune it up for you and it's also
electric too
both of them let's get that out there
there you go yeah look at that jam up
for us one time man
while we get out of that the g it's
gonna be tougher on a acoustic
almost now you can put your pinky there
right there
and then he's gotta go down one more the
fret he's on like the third fret oh he's
third
okay yeah put it down man just move this
just move it up a little there you go oh
word
good jam out photos fellas don't go too
fast on them chappelle just yeah
let me tune it for you
[Music]
and then don't touch the other strings
with your fingers just the ones that
you're on
just the ones that you're on so like
so which ones am i on so remember that
third
third fret here yep top string okay
it's beautiful beautiful right that's a
freaking dope guitar it seems like a
really dope guitar
yeah go ahead just rock out for us a
little bit brenden
all right take some time but you get in
there there it is
you know what t-fat kz
we appreciate everyone all day you know
what's better than one guitar
two and it takes two to guitars
hell yeah you know you're welcome dude
love is tight love his game
learning to play well that's a that's a
really fun guitar there man
it's acoustic electric oh that is
bam right there sick
that's dope damn dawg
you gotta learn to play now yeah you
gotta hit up uh steady bills or whatever
his name is
maybe i'll know how to play or leslie
beals sandy belts
that's sick yeah man that was beautiful
oh you know the kids are gonna love that
too love it
yeah dad's about to rock out don't let
him touch that one
yeah no that's dope thank you
wow first guitar first guitar and you
got
ramone socks what's up dog yeah i like
those socks on it's just punched
song though all right can you
are they super they're really popular
huge
yeah like what's their most famous song
blitzkrieg bop
that's probably the biggest one how's
that go uh
they're british right no okay from new
york
all right are we ending on that channel
you got current event
i don't know how we could top the guitar
i know that's good ending
yeah there's some hayek what happened i
love her
she's 54 years old oh my god she's 54
54. i want to say that's her body right
there
super bodied you know i met her at
sundance oh you did really yeah she's
very cool very chill
i got a picture with her did you go with
brian no i was solo when i was on
my movie netflix called bernie sands if
anybody want to watch that
okay like you remember this show i
[ __ ] love and our boy is on it
uh uh what the [ __ ] with baron davis
you know oh yeah yes uh ron taylor on
that ron taylor he killed him i love
that
wait what is it called what the [ __ ]
davis yeah
speaking of that yeah wait what is that
yeah oh yeah they
yeah yeah point four billion it's
[ __ ] to buy from adidas
interesting i don't know adidas had
reebok they need to reduce
they need to do the yeah that would be
great they need to make reebok cool
again yeah that'd be hard though they're
just not
cool you never had a pair of even ever
since i had iverson okay
i had some of the classics yeah i had
their i rocked a lot of the classics
that was big yeah
yeah but yeah you just don't have
anything cool like you're not gonna rock
reeboks today
yeah maybe the white and red iverson's
the white black iversons
i still people see rocking the iverson
yeah rick ross had uh tried to bring
reeboks back
they just yeah they'd be smart to sell
it to them that'd be dope
yeah yeah that band dave show so fun
though yeah i like it
it's a tv show it's kind of like his
version of larry david
really i got it what's it on ron taylor
is so funny ron taylor
is [ __ ] hilarious he's so [ __ ]
talented he's so
talented yeah he's great uh yeah they
got a
uh melvin greg in there uh what's the
guy it's so [ __ ] funny i gotta check
this out now it's great it's on fuse tv
fuse tv it's it's it's not it's it's
it's it's on youtube though
episodes on youtube too yeah oh god okay
yeah i gotta check it oh i love it
they're short too like 15 minutes yup oh
good
perfect and very connected a little bit
yeah he's funny man
yeah great show they canceled it though
oh they cancelled i don't know if they
cancelled or he just like stopped i'm
doing it
yeah it was for him man so he made a ton
of money then baron davis yeah
oh really good basketball i bought uh
his black santa
he had his like a clothing line he's on
the warriors and
uh he's on the warriors pelicans he was
on new orleans
new orleans but he's he got famous from
the warriors before the warriors though
he dunked over uh ak-47 was it montes
uh ellis he was really monty ellis
uh what college did he go to i don't
know what college though
over here oh yeah he's from cali
i think oh he's good on him shout out
man
yeah super baller yeah i hope they buy
reebok make them cool again that'd be
dope
i like shoes reebok is reebok's is great
bro especially the classics dude i love
the classic the gum at the bottom yeah
yeah yeah they just i haven't worn them
in there they're just not in the running
of like cool [ __ ] yeah but i think nike
adidas new balance his own who is uh oh
puma was huge
yeah puma we'd uh we didn't think he's
gonna make a comeback it's there yeah
yeah those are [ __ ] fire look at the
white and black ones chin
these no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no black those are dopes
i used to rock those all the [ __ ]
come on bro these are those are cool
[ __ ] i might get another pair yeah those
are dope how much 65
those are women okay yeah those are
women yeah i won't get the ones
that demand yeah everybody just not
remember uh british knights
yeah bks yeah british knights those are
ogs
reebok pumps that's what they're d brown
remember
the basketball oh yeah i remember the
puns but somebody what was somebody else
somebody else had the pumps as well on
there not sean kemp right
no sean kemp has some re-bucks um d
brown dude
uh shaq had uh reeboks wait what are the
barclays
nike oh those are nikes hey can you see
who shawn kim shoe is real quick sean
kemp
sure can't might ben reebok yeah it's
reebok because i'm in my head
yeah yeah as i'm saying i remember i had
those chairs
sure bro used to ball with those those
are my favorite remember
bro bad those was my [ __ ] brother
terrible what
i do a lot i know a lot of people that
rock doors bring up the shack reeboks
uh kendrick lamar's first collab was
with me that's what we said yeah we just
looked at it yeah
court says it was fire
yeah those are so terrible shacks and
then they had the pumps
and then shaq made his shoes cheap yeah
right he went with his own made him
cheap sort of
a large one the pumps man did he make
good money off that
jack i don't know he stopped doing it he
couldn't make good money
they all look kind of bad yeah they're
not good and i always thought when i was
a kid that the pump made it
so you can jump higher on the bottom
then you found out just yeah
it just makes a regular shot hey you
remember when basketball oh no but
basketball they had this little shoe
and you had like this little circle on
the front of your shoe you had to walk
on your
uh oh you're talking about the jump
souls the jump to make you jump higher
yeah i used to walk around
high school i think they were i used to
wear them all the time you did what yo
literally make you run faster jump
higher jump souls shove them to your
shoes
them right there yeah the black yeah the
black ones yeah
those you guys ever have soaps what do
you mean
you've never seen they're like those no
these escape shoes oh no
you can grind with them did you feel
different when you get over them oh yeah
oh my god that was right there
which one so they had this thing in the
middle to where you could like go across
the ledge
like a rail oh no you know he's talking
about yeah
that was just for me look at you
guys around the school were they big uh
in like that extreme sports community
yeah
it's fascinating cool
leaving last night what else you got jen
i think that's about it
maybe all right oh this is a nice story
this isn't atlanta
a homeless dude saved 16 dogs and cats
so i think 10
10 dogs six cats are the other way
around uh the
the shelter for the dogs and cats was
burning somehow he has something with
the owner where he has a pit bull as
well he's almost got
like since he was 13 and they keep his
dog over at night
and then he could pick it up in the
morning yeah so you stay here's a
question
if you're a dog would you rather be
would you rather have your owner be like
like rich or homeless because you're
always outside
oh yeah you know like is it better for a
dog if they're if the owner is homeless
because they're always doing [ __ ]
outside yeah yeah
just kind of living doing the day you
know if you know what's funny about us
humans
so we'll see like a homeless guy with a
homeless dog and we'll feel sorry for
the dog
well not i mean because dog has no
choice yeah i saw i saw like a couple
years ago in l.a
i forgot he was a they flipped out on
the dude right yeah or they remember
that
yeah they're trying to take his dog dog
to take his dog
it was kind of hard yeah that was
unfortunate yeah that was it was like
sad you know again is it better for the
dog if he's is his
owner's homeless i don't know i don't
know is the dog happier because he's
just chilling outside
four seven yeah i know could be fun
if you're if you're a dog yeah i'll
deliver it yeah as long as he has food
and water yeah that's what i'm saying
mm-hmm
and homeless people with dogs those dogs
are that's
well trained no they are they don't the
welshes yeah they know
it's weird that's true
that's it all right all right man well
this crew is in
palm beach florida this thursday friday
saturday kids
come see us bringing the new years the
right way will be in
florida this week tickets at tfk.com
san marcos texas end of the month
january 29th through the 30th
at the mark in san marcos texas come
and get it sick boy everything thick boy
thickboy.com
that's it we love you guys happy new
years let's have a good year 2021.
can't come fast enough thank you guys
for listening supporting this podcast
it's been a beast of a 2020 uh 2021 is
gonna be good man all right love you
guys we're out